we get it sometimes kid-friendly films
are just plain unbearable for adults
filmmakers understand this too and often
try to add things that make being
trapped in a theater with a hundred
sniffling kids more tolerable
occasionally however they go a little
too far here are a few adult jokes we
can't believe they allowed in kids
movies inside out Pixar's 2015 animated
feature inside out was obviously
kid-friendly being Pixar and all there
was however one joke that push the
envelope just a bit was that was it beer
it's better there were no bears in San
Francisco I saw a really Airy guy you
look like a bear if you've ever taken a
stroll through the Castro district in
San Francisco you probably know exactly
what anchor is talking about Aladdin in
the king of thieves and the third
installment of Disney's Aladdin
franchise our hero finally gets the girl
since this was a directed video
production Robin Williams who returned
as the hilarious genie made a bawdy joke
that maybe shouldn't have made it past
the editors I talked the earth wasn't
supposed to move until the honeymoon get
it yeah you get it and of course this
wouldn't be the first time Disney got a
little frisky mrs. Doubtfire Robin
Williams has given free reign when it
came to his improvisation and mrs.
Doubtfire with the understanding that
the final film would be cut to a still
family-friendly if a little cheeky pg-13
rating Williams got so risque with his
off-the-wall freestyling but there's
another unseen version of the movie
which is rated nc-17 we're not sure how
much more suggestive it could get to
this however difficult on payment huh
excuse me
sink the soap hide the weasel park the
porpoise bit of the old Humpty Dumpty
little Jack horny the horizontal mambo
hmm just a fire a bone dancer
Rumple Force clunk baloney pop the old
cunning linguistics hmm is it half at
least
scooby-doo and a live-action adaptation
of scooby-doo the gang takes a flight to
spooky island along the way shaggy finds
himself unexpectedly seated next to a
blonde bombshell on the airplane who
introduces herself I'm gonna change like
that is my favorite name yeah thanks
Warner Brothers for finally confirming
what fans have suspected all along now
we know why Shaggy's always got the
munchies like my favorite a double
triple decker sardine and marshmallow
fudge sandwich the road to El Dorado in
this DreamWorks animated adventure our
hero Tulio falls in love with a lovely
shell and the pair spend some quality
time together but in one particular
scene the film goes from romantic to
downright explicit whoa my moles hello
sure does look like the animators were
going for something a little more
serious than kissing Muppet Treasure
Island it's in Muffet Treasure Island
that we learned that Kermit the Frog
sometime girlfriend Miss Piggy or
benjamina good in the context of this
film has been seeing some other guys
like Long John Silver well more than
seeing this seems to be your day for
renewing old acquaintances
- oh no him - thanks for that
Muppets dad what's a muppet well it's
not quite um up it's not quite a puppet
but man so to answer your question I
don't know The Brave Little Toaster to
the rescue
the riders behind The Brave Little
Toaster to the rescue didn't even bother
to hide this one which comes complete
with soft chest bedroom music wow what's
happening fricken Stein is searching
through all my files searching through
regions heretofore only dreams of fun
man woo that feels sort of good what
does my memory banks are being stroked
and by an expert
I feel something something happening
inside of me and I can't keep it to
myself any longer no your eyes and ears
aren't fooling you that was the grossest
thing you've seen a computer do all day
and considering what most computers are
used for these days that's really saying
something
teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles during one
notable scene in the 2014 Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles reboot the huge heroic
reptiles are introduced to reporter
April O'Neil as Raphael tries to get her
to hand over the photo she just snapped
we can hear this sleazy remark so hot I
can feel my shell tightening we can hear
you we can hear him - time to watch our
ears till they bleed thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know your favorite adult jokes and kids
movies
you